premier conseil des ministres pour le
nouveau ministre délégué à la santé
bernard kouchner bernard kouchner qui a
manifesté son plaisir de travailler avec
elisabeth guigou en précisant que cette
fonction allait un peu le changer après
le kosovo reportage arnaud boutet et
alain poirier dans les travées de
l'hémicycle bernard kouchner ça lui
sourit
certains de ses amis sont là et il ne
veut oublier personne depuis ce matin le
nouveau ministre délégué à la santé
affiche la même satisfaction à la sortie
du conseil des ministres
il prend son ministre de tutelle par le
bras elisabeth guigou bernard kouchner
le duo de charme pause et enchaîne les
amabilités
nous parlerons le plus souvent possible
à 2 si vous le permettez valable
/
rarement en tout cas je suis très
heureuse qu'il arrive je suis très
heureux d'être là ça me change un peu
pas de rivalité donc au contraire les
deux ministres soignent leur bonheur
apparent il précise que la répartition
des dossiers a déjà commencé la maîtrise
des dépenses de santé la vache folle
voilà ce qui attend bernard kouchner
autre ambiance à la sortie de dominique
gillot ses attributions sont désormais
réduites
elle refuse d'y voir là une sanction ses
déclarations sur le nombre de morts
causées par la maladie de la vache folle
ont pu choquer elle s'en étonne encore
aujourd'hui les quelques journalistes
qui ont considéré que j'avais eu des
propos malencontreux ils ont écouté
l'avenir nous dira comment l'histoire
analysera 7,7 réponse
le populaire bernard kouchner renforce
donc le gouvernement c'est important
pour l'image de l'équipe jospin en
pleine période électorale